والله هذا يطرح كشعار ولكن واضح ان
المؤسسه العسكريه في السودان لها خبره
سياسيه ضخمه وراكم التجارب وهم يدرسون
التكتيك والمناوره ولذلك يريدون التدخل في
العمل السياسي طيله عهد الانقاذ كانت كل
مره اتصل فيها المفاوضات السلام مع الحركه
الشعبيه الى مرحله تسبق التوقيع ينهار
لانه الجيش يتحرك ويحتل مدينه فهو غارق في
السياسه متعمق فيها يجيد اللعب فيها باكثر
مما يجيد المدنيون فلذلك لن يخرج بهذه
السهوله هي صيقه المصالحه التي كان يسميها
الاستاذ منصور خالد العوده الى منصه
التاسيس تشمل حتى نظريه امن قومي للبلاد
واذا كانت نظريه امن قومي سيكون هنالك
عقيده عسكريه متفق عليها هنالك ينبغي ان
يقوم مؤتمر للنظام الحكم يحدد ان السودان
يحكم فيدراليا الفيدراليه لها شرطين لابد
منهما هما الجيش الواحد والديمقراطيه
فلذلك الجهد الفكري
والرؤيه هي مهمه نحن نحتاج الان الى افكار
ونحتاج الى قدر هائل جدا من
التسامحين
في السودان انت متفائل ولا لا والله
بوصف يعني
مفكر سياسي ينبغي ان ابذل افكار تساعد على
التفاؤل انا قلت ان هنالك تجارب ولكن
حقيقه الحده القائمه الان في الساحه
السياسيه بين اطرافها المختلفه والخلافه
العسكري يجعل الانسان اقرب للتشاؤم منه
الى التفاؤل